One further nuance to mention about associations, is the idea of links.
Just like classes can have instances, associations can have links. For
example, if we had the situation where a company hires people,
we might have a situation where IBM hires Bob. IBM hires Alice.
Hewlett-Packard hires Tom. Hewlett-Packard hires Alice.
She has two, two jobs. In this situation, we would have four different links.
One for each pair involved in the association. Notice in this particular
diagram that in addition to indicating all of the particular instances
of the classes, that the lines here are going to indicate links.
That is lines between rectangles for
which the rectangles are instances indicate links, that participate
in association. Notice also that we have role names here and we have qualifiers.